and welcome to a blue to report live
Skype session I am here with mjf of all
weight wrestling and Jeff right off the
bat thank you for being here I'm
completely miserable and I hope this
goes by quick and painlessly but I have
a feeling it's not going to Harris so
let's try to make this snappy perfect
will do so 2019 has been quite the year
for you so far what looking back on it
what do you consider a highlight of 2019
I think the highlight was the second I
kicked that to face no good piece for me
at least I think anyone who watches it
back you can instantly see that it was
almost like there was a ton maybe five
tons of weight being shed off my
shoulders it was an incredibly great
moment I couldn't have been happier with
what I did
cuz quite frankly he's a bad human being
and he had it coming and I just now I
could finally go on my own it's my turn
I don't have to worry about some schmuck
trying to hold me down anymore now if
you thought what I've done so far has
been insane just you wait
I think I know I know I know I'm er D
honestly the biggest name in all the
wrestling I'm the one who everybody
can't no one can keep my name as her
mouth right now everybody's saying that
I'm the guy everybody's saying I'm the
face of this company and it feels right
yeah I was going to bring up Kody's so
can you go into detail a little bit on
why you decided to to make that decision
to cap a relationship with Kody well
Aires if you tuned in last week which
I'm sure you did as did everybody
because everybody knew I was going to
explain the why um I went into the fact
that de Cody that you people all know
and love is not the real Cody the real
Cody is somebody that took advantage of
a young kid that he knew us much more
talent too than him much more better
looking much more charismatic and he
said to himself I'm gonna make sure that
this kid can't one-up me I'm gonna keep
this kid in a little pigeonhole and when
I'm done being the guy I'll let him
frolic out of that hole but I realized
that real quick
I wish I'd realized it quicker in all
honesty I wish I had turned on Cody
Rhodes quicker but the fact of the
matter is Cody Rhodes turned on me the
second we made eye contact so was this a
tough decision is this something that
you've been considering for a while now
to turn on him like you said yeah it was
a very tough decision I mean I was
looking at somebody that I thought was
my friend my mentor a father figure a
big brother I mean I can go on and on
with the analogies when he was in the
walls and Chris had him in his patented
submission old I was looking at him and
he was in complete agony and I knew that
if the hold were to continue um Cody
wouldn't be you know injured and out for
a few months Cody would be done his ribs
weren't would be broken and shattered
his back would be broken and shattered
his knees would be broken and shattered
his neck would be broken and shattered I
mean he was wrapped up like a pretzel
and I took it upon myself to threw that
towel in because I cared about Cody what
I didn't realize was Cody didn't care
about me so as I'm trying to check out
my friend and make sure he's okay
all he keeps mumbling under his breath
is I can't believe you just did that
what you can't believe I just saved your
career he's ungrateful and he was
ungrateful of the fact that I took all
his advice in stride for the past year
and a half and I accepted this man into
my life thinking he cared about me he
didn't care about me man and that was
that was the last straw for me was that
moment when I was looking at this guy
whose career I literally just saved and
he he wasn't thankful he wasn't
appreciative he had a look of disgust on
his face as did the rest of the crowd
yeah you mentioned the rest of the crowd
I mean the way you explained this it all
sounds very reasonable but obviously
many fans especially that one particular
fan that threw the drink at you were
very unhappy what were media thoughts
when you saw the fan throw that drink at
you my thoughts are these people are
misinformed they are sheep and it is my
job now to try to explain to these
people that I'm the good guy here I'm
gonna salt to the earth not Cody not
your figurehead not Cody Rhodes mjf I'm
the guy you should
be cheering for because I'm the realist
here I am the realest human being on our
roster everybody else is playing
somebody everybody else is trying to
portray a superhuman aspect try to be a
superhero of themselves I'm I'm just me
I always have been nothing about me is
fake nothing and you know who's really
fake you knows the fakest out of
everyone Cody Rhodes the exact same guy
that you guys are cheering for at the
top of your lungs so I I pity you people
I'm not upset with you I pity you people
because you don't know better but you
will you will soon enough and that's
that's not an issue it's gonna be a
non-issue very soon
you've now aligned yourself with Wardlow
who looked like an absolute beast last
week what should fans know about Lowe
let me tell you something
Ward Lowe is a blue chipper Wardlow is a
genetic freak Wardlow is I like to call
him mr. mayhem the guy could literally
and I've seen it myself
the man deadlifts 800 pounds he benches
750 he's a freak of nature um he is
I honestly think he's 300 plus pounds
he's just he's a freak but the thing is
that that's the difference between me
and Cody that people gonna realize real
quick I'm not going to use this man I
care about Wardlow as a human being why
because I'm not a two-faced piece of
like Cody Rhodes I want to help more
glow I want to be Ward Lowe's mouthpiece
I want to make sure that Warren low
along with me and he can come on the
ride as I ascend to the top of this
company but I'm not gonna feed him
little bread crumbs like he's some duck
following behind me I'm gonna make sure
that he's treated with respect proper
respect and that's what I'm most excited
for me and Wardlow are going to take
over all elite wrestling and we're gonna
do it really quick and really efficient
well I was just gonna ask 2019 is
obviously coming to a close what are
your accomplishments and hopes for 2020
what are your new year's resolutions for
2020 I'm gonna be the aw world
heavyweight champ
I know it you know it everyone who's
watching this video knows it the
question is when I happen to like Chris
Jericho I have a great deal of respect
for Chris as anyone who saw you know
last week I really like the guy right
now what I have to do is ensure that I
get continuous victory so I becoming the
number one contendership spot to wrestle
this man that I respect but I can assure
you and I could say this with an
absolutely straight face I am better
than Chris Jericho in the microphone in
the ring in my trunks in my boots in the
arena in in a parking lot in a hotel
room in a bar I can take on Chris
Jericho one-on-one and I will win
handedly um but again that's not me
dissing Chris Chris is a hell of a
talent I'm just that much better
last question for you we saw outside of
the Ring you make your commentary debut
on a W dark are we should we expect more
of that in in recent weeks or was that
just always right look I like TK TK is
one of my close friends if you're not
aware of TK isn't that's going over your
head that's Tony Khan the billionaire
who owns my company we chill a lot and
yes he compensated me very well to do
commentary that day but I told him look
I am hands-down clearly the best
commentator in the sport today
especially after the outing I had no one
can touch me if you want me to do this
again it's not gonna be cheap so you
know that's up to the fans that's up to
the fans
adding TK go and hey I think it's worth
spending XYZ amount of money in order to
ensure that we see him behind the table
again but to be fair what I'm trying to
concentrate on right now is getting into
that number one contendership spot and
when I'm also concentrating on is ending
Cody Rhodes because Cody Rhodes is bad
for business
Cody Rhodes is bad for the sport of
professional wrestling Cody Rhodes just
a bad human being and somebody needs to
stop him immediately and that someone's
going to be me well with that being said
njf thank you for taking the time and we
hope to hear from you again sometime
soon
yeah Harris I hope I never have to look
at your stupid face ever again bye
perfect thank you